previously played for you. The really out
there things that box news host Tucker Carlson
has said, he's talked about how white supremacy
is a hoax. He has said that immigrants make
our country dirtier
and poorer. And this week he hosted a guy
named Seth Barron and brought him on to talk
about the district of Alexandria Casteo. Cortez,
a Congresswoman from New York city and Baron
was able to deliver the very salient analysis
that [inaudible] district is dirty and it's
dirty because you've got immigrants, you've
got pig grease, you've got trash, and it's
not a very American district. This apparently
counts as analysis on Tucker Carlson's program.
If you're watching, you'll notice that at
the bottom of the screen there's something
like Tucker investigates you. This is considered
an, this is investigative journalism. Getting
a guy on to say that there's pig grease and
it's dirty cause there's a lot of non-Americans
in [inaudible] district. Let's take a look
at the video.
We're kind of source of irony on the show.
But if you claim to care about the environment,
you think that the little piece of America
you're responsible for the represent in the
Congress would be clean. But hers isn't. Why?
Well, a part of the reason is because, uh,
her district is actually one of the least
American districts in the country. And by
that I don't mean that it's not part of America,
but it's occupied by relatively few American
citizens. Uh, a very high percentage of, of
her district is in fact illegal aliens. Um,
now the way they inhabit housing there is
such that they live in a lot of illegal spaces
like basements and many people live there,
so they wind up producing a lot of garbage
that the landlords don't want thrown out normally.
So hence you wind up with a lot of garbage
on the streets. You have illegal food vendors
pouring their pig grease into the gutters.
Yeah, I mean, I worked out there. It's, it's,
it can be a little gross.
Why isn't it clean? Well, there's lots of
non-Americans and there's pig grease and there's
trash. So there's a few layers to this that
are important to discuss. First of all, once
again, Tucker Carlson crafts and narrative
on his show of the dirty, not white immigrant.
The country is cleaner. When we have just
good old boy Americans, it's better run. Uh,
and we're just better off in always. That's
the narrative that continues to be crafted
and curated on Tucker Carlson's program. That's
not new. It's also not new. That Fox news
seems completely fine with this being the
narrative that Tucker Carlson is crafting
and espousing. Now the reality is that aside
from the argument about, you know, being more
or less American, that's a ridiculous argument.
Poverty is overwhelmingly in red States run
by Republican governors and or Republican
legislatures with what they call conservative
political policy. It's very easy to pick a
huge city, the biggest city in the country.
It's even easier to pick like a specific area
of a huge city and point out how conditions
aren't good. But we're talking about huge
cities. When you have more population density
aside from whether AOC is or isn't your representative,
and by the way, she's only been sworn in for
what, 11 months or something like that, you
are going to be able to find trash on the
streets or there is going to be pig grease
or whatever it is that this, this clown is
talking about. If you really want to do this
in a serious way, like let's pretend for a
second that this isn't just another attempt
to, uh, post facto find ways to criticize
AOC and to criticize nonwhite immigrants to
the United States. Let's say you really want
to do this. If you zoom out, you would see,
wait a second. The poorest States are Mississippi
and Louisiana and New Mexico, West Virginia,
Kentucky, Alabama.
These are Republican States. These are New
Mexico. Okay? It's more of a 50, 50. Then
you see Washington D C in there with a lot
of poverty. Of course, Washington D C is sort
of a, it's a state that's a city. It's not
a state, but it's, it's only a city. So when
you consider that the places with the highest
population density are going to tend towards
having more people living in poverty, then
it just continues with Arkansas, Oklahoma,
South Carolina, Tennessee. Are you seeing
the trend here? Arizona is a 50, 50 state,
but then you've got Georgia and Texas and
North Carolina. Only then do you get to States
like Michigan and New York in terms of poverty
rate rates. So I get that it makes really
great red meat for Fox news viewers to talk
about those dirty, dirty New York city immigrants.
And those liberals all packed together with
that socialist AOC leading them, who by the
way, has only been leading them for a let
representing them for 11 months.
And there's pig grease and trash and Brown
people. But the poverty problem in the United
States is overwhelmingly and disproportionately
in red States. States that by the way, are
heavily subsidized by taxes paid in by blue
States and given back out by the federal government
to red States. They talk about small government
conservatism. They talk about reducing taxes
and getting the federal government out of
States as much as possible. Well, if they
did that, a lot of those red States would
be even worse off than they are today because
they are so heavily subsidized by blue States
like California and Massachusetts and New
York and so many others. Now, of course, it's
very popular for these right wingers to, let's
now talk about policy. They love talking about
how urban cities are places of blight and
chaos and crime and pig grease apparently.
But the other hypocrisy is that they also
oppose all of the ideas and proposals to deal
with issues that the United States has in
cities.
Housing, well, let's build affordable housing.
We have a huge affordability crisis and inventory
crisis when it comes to housing in a lot of
these big cities, now they're against that.
Rent controls subsidies, they're against that.
Make sure everybody has healthcare so that
they don't fill up urban emergency rooms without
insurance raising everyone's rates now. They
don't want that either. And on and on and
on. So to sum up what they do, they lie about
the problem. They then oppose the strategies
to fix the parts of the problem that are real.
And then the Fox news audience gets this completely
harebrained analysis, if you can even call
it that. And they say, that's it, that's the
problem. And then the talking points become
codified in Republican orthodoxy. I wish I
could play a bigger role in fixing it. I'm
doing what I can. It is depressing that it
just does not seem, uh, it's not easily fixable
is I think the point I'm trying to make.